hey how's it going it is Monday and Mike
and I are here to play battlegrounds for
our weekly battleground stream this is
called the sheriff of Rock because if
you've watched the previous ones you
know that Mike is the sheriff of Rock or
something coming to my town you get you
get shot yeah unless you go by the rules
all right well it looks like the game
and pip haven't been changed since last
time so they look like that we're not
gonna do that we're just gonna go with
the game yeah I don't need our dumb
faces already up already up as well
let's do this this is not my badge by
the way it says Matthew on it that is
not my name I also have this gun here
you just turned the PIP off you're right
jake has a nerf gun I've been wearing
and in it this is my character
so did I tell you story Jake the first
time I ever played I thought this itself
was the match you know everybody started
here not only had he told me that but I
think you've said it on the stream
really it's still funny I think is
because it was just terrifying I went to
grab a gun and get that H out of here we
are fixing the camera right now so we'll
have that up soon
I'm hoping the flight path goes over
Ra'zac me too because uh that's that's
your hometown yeah born and raised in
Roz Hawk battlegrounds
can you not go first person anymore in
here maybe not interesting cool alright
oh no it's way out of our range what are
we gonna do I'm not gonna put you on it
you just list you well I mean you're
like alright let's do it let's do it
let's go in the everybody :
this is gonna be we're not gonna reach
that let's go to these house right here
oh yeah well alright 1 2 3 I've always
wanted some sort of like metal music to
be playing right now yeah rain which I
kind of like yeah dampen some noise
alright I'm just dropping right now yeah
oh man hopefully there's stuff in this
farmhouse cuz we definitely could have
read for [ __ ] right there's a lot of
people the pit is back so you can see
our faces for better or worse I have to
get chat back up though now sorry for
these slight technical difficulties but
I think we're I think we're alone in
this nearest farm house oh I am still at
first but there's so many people landing
and put [ __ ] nice so I'm hoping
hopefully this is running better on
stream that I'm seeing right now
keep that Otto Schott II dude I think
you're spoiled with your setup over
there I could take it easy if you don't
mind and a backpackers now you can take
the backpack no I'll take it
crossbow here if you care oh here we go
m16 do you have any uh five five six or
not five five six seven seven six - nope
I just landings gentlemen I heard pub G
was releasing on Xbox one in game
preview mode on eight sixteen seventeen
true any validity it I don't know
nothing I heard maybe I missed some news
that'd be awesome
oh wait 8:16 august no I don't think so
damn I'm actually getting hooked up here
I got a red dot so if you want I get
just kind of two times not to work I've
got a level two backpack - on my level
one not to worry everyone I'll take the
level two backpack I have not played in
two weeks so I'm sure this will go
swimmingly
last time I scream jean-luc said it for
me last week because what was I doing I
don't know I was out of work in the
morning oh my god
got a four x go I'm getting hooked up
holographic here if you want it yeah
dude I have a lot of sights I'm gonna
keep them for you I have a 2 x I'll keep
for you wait you can you use it yet or
no a 2 x we in the circle actually uh
man I was getting nervous everytime it
like looks like it's gonna go onto the
bridges
I have to all tap out quickly because
first-person mode is uh it's live right
there is it what it's first-person mode
live it's it's live for the bait you can
do like a bit like a PTR kind of thing
cool yeah I just saw commander Jean
Shepard right now I have a little time
look at this chat I definitely wanted to
try it out I know Jake does I played a
little bit of it it's kind of janky at
the moment I'm at riot I think it looks
like it's available on regular - I don't
know man
well we'll see how what's yeah see how
we do mm-hmm go all out Rambo loud and
vicious gube says that well got loud oh
I hear some gunshots we move into the
city that's the the opposite way which
we should be going but sure down south I
mean I see you've already kind of
started god dammit the Bandit of Poe
[ __ ] wants to go home people are
messing with his town did you change
your hair color no yeah you want to get
out of this farmhouse cuz people are
gonna be swarming it in a few seconds
yeah
what he might go just to these this
clump first yeah sure no we could it
would be wiser to circle around this way
right no that's all the flight path the
flight path was like right across here
anywhere we go right now like the best
thing they just go yellow alright I
don't know if we're gonna get like we
need a car to actually get around all
this stuff you know you're well-equipped
when your jacket has fur around your
neck we're ready to survive what I
really want to pull one of those in a
box I really like those jackets the only
thing is like it's mines white it's not
the best camo well I guess if you're in
the dirt the camo doesn't
nobody you have a best yeah I need one
group of houses there's a dumb houses I
guess I can take these shotgun rounds
word cool
uh yeah I'm feeling good I got a four
time scope is this my for time scope
I hope yeah as four times do you need at
two times oh I found at M 469 wool
frying pan here we go there's a level
two helmet okay want this do you want
this auto shotgun No thank you I've got
my ez there's a level two helm you've
already got what you said you at times
to scope for me yeah me I got to get
this handgun quick I don't have one
actually a shock damn we're actually not
doing too badly with uh I know for not
landing in a good area all right sweet
I'm gonna take all this nine million for
my booze
all right I imagine there's gonna be
coming from this yeah that's what I was
thinking um should we find your like
what we just like let's get across this
road for snow I don't want to go to
those how about over here
wow that's still out in the open I just
don't to go across these farmland feet
about field let's go to yellow for now
you wanna do that okay okay let's be
careful because yeah I agree there's
someone in twitch ad says thoughts on
first person only servers I've only
played a couple games and I found it
much more difficult which I think was is
to be expected it's a little bit janky
though you can tell that this game
wasn't necessarily designed to be played
in first so I have a feeling the reason
it's in beta right now is because
they're still working out the kinks
spread out a little more my fault um
we'll definitely give it a shot though
in this stream did we must be coming
across someone soon yeah there's a red
dot on yeah a red dot here if you want a
pink okay got times two and a
holographic
to take this picture I'm Meg from it
Luzi hopefully no one's in here some not
really even paying attention I got a
frying pan
oh here's the best thank you something
I'll be right out I got a there we go
another times to scope I'm all set man
damn that Thunder hi okay I feel very
exposed sheriff needs his deputy
all right I'm in sweet these houses
these ones always have decent stuff in
it which painkillers like I always find
good stuff in these kinda help boss we
got a suppressor I don't need this red
dot I don't yeah I guess I'll put it on
my handgun no say you you got a health
pack or yeah okay
those hills to the north that we just
came down yeah so nervous I don't think
we should move much more yeah we could
hang out keep the doors closed while
we're I'm gonna go check out this other
building I wish there was a window yeah
these ones always have bad sight lines I
feel like a little too backpacked y'all
ready have one oh no I don't it's in
here
shotgun shut you don't have a shotgun do
you have a shotgun do you would you find
you find a choke oh I thought you
swapped out what do you what uh what do
you have an automatic shotgun and m416 I
thought I had an a key I didn't have an
8k gotcha
um yeah I feel like it's a matter of
time before people start coming this way
did you call that door behind you over
there yeah she's no good up there yeah
house was kind of suck huh be better off
getting behind the fence but then again
that's not really good cover
gube is eaten chicken dinner film right
now rooting for us it makes no sense
it's like one o'clock on the East Coast
get your [ __ ] together do
yeah I don't like these houses at all
but they could so easily come in the
front door and I would not see it coming
whatsoever I feel like everyone
hopefully like only two people survive
with [ __ ] I hope so
I mean fifty people are dead already
well almost fifty people are dead
already
still nothing this rain could
potentially mask some footsteps man I
feel really weird we should move a
second let me check this out bombing
from that angle how about I say we get
across these fields while we can let's
go for the the drop wanna go to yellow
for now sure
stay low across these fields I'd rather
do this now but then but when
everybody's going through here which I
guess could be happening soon let's go
out one by one you go first ah stick to
these trees bushes I guess that's
Thunder
oh I don't like this nope
yeah I get to those bushes up straight
ahead we don't necessary have to go to
yellow that's just the only building oh
I'm being shot at oh they're back at the
house we just left all right I'm down
there I don't think you'd see me I see
both of them there's one at 15 going
right toward that house and then there's
another one at the house on the right
okay Shay you got messed up you could
heal they're not gonna hit you we've got
time then there's no way they're gonna
see you I just wanna move because they
were shooting at me but yeah yeah okay
um just say hello for now get I'm gonna
get over this Ridge did you kind of see
where they were yeah I did they're I
think one is in each house right now the
one that was shooting at you was on the
in the right house your health looks
decent actually I just
damn I want a crouch and look at them
cuz that before times I'd be able to see
them but they'll also shoot my face I
can't remember though those windows on
this side weren't that they boarded up
yeah but I'm gonna keep moving I'm just
a pro until we're out of their range oh
yeah they're both in the right house now
I can't see my screen is too small it
looks dark I'm just looking a different
way
yeah they're definitely in that right
house hello from Amsterdam why not
first-person only mode uh we'll give
that a try we have a plane wow so we're
gonna do some warm-up we could probably
get up and go [ __ ] how far away is that
you're gonna have to move yeah they are
let's go to yellow ish I feel like
everybody's gonna go to where I just
mark though well are they moving now
then I kind of hold on a second I'm
gonna get up in one of these bushes and
see if I can see them [ __ ] I don't know
okay I have times two so I mean I yeah
okay they're running down the road I
don't know if I want to try that running
they gave up on us we might as well do
the same okay
keep keep an eye on like you're right in
our six because they could very well
have just made the same exact like path
changes we did also I'm really not
feeling good about where I just marked
yellow so let's kind of hunker down and
figure out a different thing at some
point you think they're gonna try to
shoot us I could still see them no I
don't think so they're too far away wait
did they just cut into the field to a
second
oh they just they're booking it down the
road like this road right here
uh the one - no no you're good
jeez I hate this part of the maps so
much it's really good concealment but
there's no cover if you know where they
are
yeah and if you have time to like slowly
inch along everything epi mode seems
like it wouldn't be as much fun I didn't
think it was as fun it was kind of
frustrating
sorry that's uh interrupt how about we
go I don't want to go toward the bridge
yet we should get a boat honestly okay
but I those the buildings at yellow are
gonna be swarming I feel like all
there's a car like an empty nevermind no
sorry it was driving along it avoided us
though let's go up in these hills at
least for now I think we've got time
from the circle damn there's like I just
saw two different there's three
different Jeeps going all go in toward
the circle you say you're getting shot
no I just said we're alright I'm gonna
hang hang out this Shack quick oh that's
not us was it no there's something on
this picnic table I think it's a frying
pan yeah I read our Oscar Sarita says
give me a shout-out we've got a yellow
Rita we're gonna have to do some
fighting it but yellow I think probably
uh hold on a second yeah alright is
yellow the light now encephalitis yeah
let's just go along the coast I would
say get to the coast and then go along
at toward yellow should we kind of wing
out a little bit which way like maybe
not across across you cover
no boat so many years their bridges
right here Oh Oh God
is that it you see someone thought so no
it's just a texture pop-in all right
we're close enough I don't see a boat
either they're probably on the other
side of the bridge we can't go that far
away from the circle right now let's go
over to yellow just get ready to do some
shooting it's been far too simple of a
match so far aside from it a three time
do you got hit
did they a nighttime or something the
color looks a bit different or is it
more it's more foggy I think yeah there
are nighttime ish like dusk
that'd be scary if there was a nighttime
that'd be awesome
it would be awesome so yeah sure hang
glide to safety
okay um I don't feel good
wait isn't it no it's a burnt-out car
let's stick man all these doors are open
to let's get behind those rocks on the
coast maybe there might be a better bet
they spread out we're pretty close
starts swimming no well yeah what are we
gonna do after this like at least you're
thinking ahead like I don't see a boat
dude these houses must start swimming
okay so haulin let's just stay on the
edge of the circle for now and figure
this out because there's got to be
people here
keep an eye on these buildings I don't
feel good about them I heard gunshots
somewhere all right so we're in the
circle that's fine but happen yeah what
do we do after this I think about a boat
is our best bet or swimming but
definitely not the bridge you want to
swim we're gonna do that now get in like
we're not like particularly close to it
yeah but I don't know if I want I don't
want to climb down these rocks with the
book you just got reviewing it you
something yeah I think a little bit of
damage gotta go this way
okay alright swimming but what if uh
yeah we gotta like stick left though
right
okay hold on a second is there a boat
you see a boat I don't know this is so
far and boring yeah I recognize the
tactical decision behind it but in terms
of excitement oh they saw a car and I
laughed really well that was
I just went underwater for a second and
the sound changed - OH - underwater
noise I thought it was someone shooting
oh you can see the circle we're screwed
damn it dude do we have a choice but to
keep swimming
no we need a boat I mean there might be
one across that's our best bet we're not
gonna make it wait is that
yeah yeah but is it in the circle that's
that's just as far I think let's just
keep going across to the beach okay oh
man holy sky in them
well we'll get to the opposite shore but
yeah just like me whatever find a car
all right
why does this always happen to us on
speaker always well that's when we need
to use our personalities and chat
engagement to entertain everyone classic
or I can shoot you with this nerf gotta
tell you to do it they with that thing
hurt I say we get to the saloon waters
book it is it quicker I'm just doing it
to stay out of I don't know if it I
don't know if it's who knows we'll make
it to the shore with plenty of time
that's kind of reassuring yeah we have a
minute and we're not
we just need to we're just across the
bridge won't we or like go past it go
under it or if you want a car were
probably gonna have to go next to it all
right um almost there
can you kind of cover me a little bit
well I don't think anybody's gonna be
over here well they might that's not
what you get run over someone beaches a
boat on top of my face while you're on
land yeah oh man you're way over there
yeah we need a car I'll go I'll go see
if I can find one it's not gonna end
like this okay oh wait no way do I see
one no it's burnt out uh let's just run
toward the circle ish let's try to kill
someone who's got a car stick to the
roads yeah might as well get over this
way I don't think gonna find a car in
time maybe you will oh I'm shot
toward you I don't think it was towards
any of us Wow let's just go to either of
us I guess
dude this circle is gonna kill us yeah
probably just we have run toward the
circle now we're not gonna make this at
all popping energy I need to pop a
painkiller well I don't have energy
drink do I
quick are quick really I hear it there's
a buggy right here he ran me over
are you serious on fire did you run you
over - no but there's a buggy nose over
then I'm getting the buggy eye dude I'm
so sorry are you live in no I'll come
get you are you are you up are you down
down dude
are you gonna survive a circle dude I
can't just go why is it always me that
doesn't get what dude you have what
laughing at him you have bad luck with
okay can you direct me a little bit
maybe can you you can't mark the math me
more can you know I kind of direct me
though
you guys never play solo and ended up in
the same game you know no no yes
oh my god there's gonna be so many
people in this little village I gotta
get out of here I'm dead win for me get
that chicken dinner
what am I going after this whole Jake
I'm so sorry I couldn't pull up the
thing yet it's still that's all right
what do I do
where's this next circle I'm getting I'm
getting there I got a buggy and I don't
care share some of that chicken dinner
with my family they're starving like
they need it yes yes yes yes no yes I
got one of them dude should I go back or
if that Gator show am I getting greedy
no he's dead
but his friend was there I'd barely
missed it should I go back yeah no dude
I got fried dough I'm getting greedy I
took one of them out that's one less
team to worry about is it possible for
the lightning bolt to hit you know oh my
god I don't think so but I thought I saw
hit balls military base action oh man I
almost got both of them the sheriff of
Roz hawk the sheriff Rock Show runnin P
points for no over question for Mike and
Jake what is your favorite desserts
chicken dinner yeah uh okay okay I've
made a serious mistake with the terrain
here yeah I'm in the Sarah you don't
even show up on my map anymore I wonder
if they got rid of that so I couldn't
like whoop whoop oh man this buggies
really paying off
Oh get go get again Jesus get it shot
sighs get out now probably get up get up
come on this is my horse the sheriff of
Rostock rides and waits for no one
all right um how about I ditch this soon
I would write like 20 people left I
would ditch that soon everyone just
watching you drive around like a like
rock walls
hey damn dingo I had no choice I
couldn't help Jake out don't put that on
me my conscience is clean and my gun is
ready to shoot all right whoa hold on a
second what should I go up there to the
weather dome yes let me let me wait here
it's way right here oh okay I got the
bug in case I'm gonna do some camping
people I'm sorry but this is a good
position bear with us what this game is
camping unless you're really good you
have to camp okay so I hate when I'm in
the position where someone could just
easily sneak up on me I don't have a
good sight line but I'll let these
people you should go back to my body and
bury me you all right
oh I hear a car should I do I do it like
it's your left oh damn it
hi did see me does he waiting for me
near the buggy and I was looking around
oh man
he had the drop on me decent warm-up I
did nothing I got a kill on accident all
right let's take it out and do it again
do we want to try and first-person mode
now mmm
let's do one in first person yeah okay
you want to do that now there you go
sure I don't know let's let's let's do
another one regular one okay and then
we'll do first pursue it what you're
gonna do when we do it yeah yeah gotcha
all right it's only indoors that's just
cuz it recognizes we're not party of two
it's only in duo's for right now Oh
interesting that works out furthest
right and first-person I think a
first-person uh solo Dan those people
got to the good side of the circle too
yeah they got too complacent my fault
things got some kick your disarming it
don't shoot yeah yeah I thought it
through
so what is the s on the hats stand for
sexy yeah I don't know oh speaking of
look at this hair that I'm rocking
frying pan give me that one more salads
now No
hey hey dang it that's what we should
name this stream the one more stream why
not let us decide yeah I mean no we'll
get in the first person will start
taking I just want out we've got how
much longer we've got like 45 more
minutes we got there well we'll open it
up don't you worry about that right now
Oh we'd be playing this all day long
though uh Jake you know what I'm seeing
Ross Hawk oh man that is the sheriff's
coming back to town get out of my town
stay out of Rostock oh man Wyatt Earp is
all right so Northside judge jury and
Cher all right one two three
don't you worry Dolores I'm coming back
I just finished Westworld finally the
other day there's a wild show I'm
kidding don't say that well how does it
end
um the army the dead finally gets there
no one's ready to fight it Joe has his
pants down it's cogs quite literally
those pants down who are we looking at
any challengers in my town I'm gonna go
for the look like it just raindrops and
we're talking three games with rain yeah
that's good
anyone oh I see one person where who
dares
oh my god one Jake look at my screen my
people five look at my screen but a lot
of them are going for it okay but yeah
oh my god this guy's right next to me
good who does he think he is doesn't he
know where we are and who I am
wait why didn't you land up on this hill
I don't know I'm cuz this is all I got a
scar I'm taking this guy out right now
yeah it's good this guy made a big
mistake drop it in my town
come out with your content hands up dang
no weapons in here this jamoke thinks
you can come into my town you're gonna
die
no one this is Raza baby um question
though where is he I don't know your
boys got a pistol of all the doors open
right there he does how do you know all
right no I've got a pistol wow you ain't
it on the complete opposite side of town
yeah I mean that's what we do though in
Rostock we divide in constitute we gotta
lock it down of course I'm the Bandit or
Roz Hawk though no I'm I'm deputizing
you for the time being well we'll we'll
figure it out later when we're the last
two people alive then we have a hard
conversation ahead of us what's this
Jamal doing oh he's right behind me are
you kidding me
I'm coming in my town oh I'll avenge you
you just embarrassed me in my own chest
does he not know oh oh
you never scar now but that's okay the
deputy's coming bandit bandit no yeah
Judy's is he in here he's got some he's
got a bone to pick oh Jesus okay that
could not have gone any worse exit to
lobby right now I don't want anyone to
witness what just happened you've just
said looks like there's a new sheriff I
saw oh my god it's not how it was
supposed to go
okay are we gonna do I got greedy no not
yet no not yet I refuse okay we're
dropping it we're going to rock
regardless of the flight path yes
okay the frying pan is Opie my
intelligence is you pee
all right
short memory nothing happened we're just
this is the first match of the day the
sheriff of Rostock needs to reclaim his
throne you think you're mixing up your
metaphors
uh-oh
Oh Mary go away Mary son Oh flipped it
she clipped it get out of here what are
you doing don't you work you could be
doing Josh is in here too they were all
here now the sheriff of Roz Hawk is it
watch gamespot stream day at twitch get
out of here aah I need Redemption yeah
that's a good point
it is their job go to another stream or
something oh man
oh geez is this gonna work are we going
above rock yes we are going above rock
this time let's try to land together
okay
good point yeah I'm no sheriff without
his deputy
I killed the share with frying pan all
right josh is gonna give it to their
social oh sweet all right the south side
at all you dog you you want to go south
telling you you always the south side
always the south side cuz you're on a
hill
Mikey South Side don't call me oh [ __ ]
we should drop 1 2 3 Cup oh I hope that
same guy somehow died oh there's another
one oh I'm so hungry for this just
everyone you fight just think of that
guy with the frying pan oh I will two
hits I didn't know the frying pan took
two hits to kill you think my afro would
have muffled the blow it should have why
else would I be having this carrot top
hair alright I'm dropping into these
ones on the southeast side oh look at
this guy is the guy right by me I'm
lower than I'm gonna land before him
let's do this kill him
do it slowly - I want blood there oh
there will be blood I'm a Mary fast I am
taking my badge off this is off the
books so you know oh there's a vehicle
here - oh that guy tried to land for the
building didn't make it probably just
took some falling down we should go
let's do it
I'm give a gun give a gun no I don't
have a gun I got my son him over I got
my steel horse here ready to go
where's yet he's a POS on the two-story
building on the other end all right I
got a handgun I got my truck
the Lucille as I call her give me that
helmet all right hear that sound Bob
Jones says hey oh hey how's it going
it's going well Bob nothing happened
just swimmingly up until this point
nothing out of the ordinary
oh there he is where he's got a crowbar
in that area though where is he he's
right outside
where are you got him oh yeah yes oh oh
I'm being shot at oh [ __ ] where I don't
know
no please Jake Jake Jake we killed his
buddy ruined his game
first person mode not yet
uh Mike died and I tried to save him but
then I died
it's about all that happened you know
what you know what I'm you know what my
problem is I figured it out um I kind of
come into it with bullets
I'm kind of going into it too aggressive
a sheriff doesn't let his emotions take
over a sheriff just kind of like I want
the Jade cam I want the Jade cam to I
think we're gonna try to get that set up
for next week I think we should rethink
I should rethink my strategy here Landon
Ross Hawk yes well that's a given
well that's the whole point of the
stream honestly is going to Roz like
whenever possible so it's not even a
matter of whether it'll be good for us
tactically I feel like it's just a
matter of pride and right now I have
none I was in Pacific enough I'm gonna
Majan this is the guy that just kill me
I wasn't picking up I was like there's a
guy outside yeah yeah but I killed that
guy still and then the other guy came
out of nowhere and rocked you I hope you
like knuckles in your mouth okay are we
looking good or what we are on the
course for Roz Hawk hell's yes I don't
know are we true I just said that mmm
everything is on the course for us ugh
we are indeed all right
cue the music do you want to do south
side or north side north please north
okay it looks like it's gonna be easier
to land on our side I don't know though
Gillian with North siders there's not as
many buildings about here no I want to
land earlier how about here not as many
building on the north side well but like
so the only building up on the cliff is
like to the very North right the rest
aren't we have to get out anyway I'm
just go to yellow okay don't do it don't
don't don't
all right
you want to go into this is anybody else
here mmm
yeah I see two other people for the
people six other people we're at a
landing in Roz Hawk no I get that
but are we gonna go for yellow still
sure I'm gonna lie I landed I landed a
barn first yeah I don't I mean they're
not no they are near me what this is
right here next to me
cut away from parachute oh my god fact
this guy gets a gun before me Jesus
Jesus
geez oh man okay I'm out of here
that guy's got something up his sleeves
yeah I'm coming please get a gun and be
ready for me because that guy's we both
just saw each other and kind of well
that was stressful
um wait did you go under spelling next
to you mmm oh the doors open oh man I do
not feel like the sheriff right now I
feel like well the sheriff usually has a
gun yeah okay I got I got stuff to heal
me if I do so need to be inclined to do
that close these doors Jake we don't
have time to close the hole we got doors
everybody says that until they eat there
is there's a pistol on the top floor are
you using it
don't tell yours why are you laughing
because it's a [ __ ] pistol whatever dude
it's a revolver what do you think I am
it I'm sure that's true it's it's on
brand yep all right let's do some
shooting all right I shouldn't be
running around like a [ __ ] up here
don't don't don't don't don't
Oh God
what what was dead where's he where's
his buddy he was he was just standing
there
good he's dead now hey let's not wait
yeah be careful looting right now
boom-boom-boom-boom GameSpot says they
think you need to turn in your badge ah
alright that goodnight hey and I got him
you have anything else he just had an 8k
and like it's been a back yeah backpack
and I think a helmet
I may have wrecked this helmet though
got a better pistol should we go to the
building next to us uh there was someone
at his a case still in the ground that's
weird looking uh I don't know it's a
good question
so we're not in the circle as people
might be leaving we're right near though
these houses suck I think someone
already went next door we can check it
out though I mean yeah I think it was
that guy who I killed
yeah I think this has been checked fat
early yeah
maybe sometimes people forget about this
area but there's nothing that's um
fingerless gloves though maybe this
building a K in here sweetie
wait where you at the building next to
that one look we ran all those other
people drop there is a holographic sight
out here too so you want to eat oh my
god he's us
where's yet I don't know go to your
right go together go the other room oh
my god where was that guy he killed me
with a shotgun you're just waiting
outside no clue but I he must know I'm
in here right where is he
I got rekt okay I'm gonna where's this
to that was horrifying he must know I'm
in here somewhere
oh god he's got these windows here
where'd he go to the right cuz the
reason he killed me is because I started
moving I've got an idea
I've run out screaming okay oh man get
that helmet got a suppressor - do I even
bother putting it on right now huh
people know there's gonna be gunshots
here where's this jamoke do i wait him
out
Oh what I thought I heard footsteps we
might be you my gameplay audio is really
low quiet
yeah there you go he's gotta be waiting
for me
he must have hurt my foot you're running
around outside
he's gotta be checking the windows right
do you hear him or is it just me no I
was like he's to the right but he's
outside not in here
do you hear now that's me oh my god
where he come from that was sick
where was he blasted you in the face the
same to both of us that was horrifying
this is the scariest thing that's that
all you wha well apart from that first
game it's not going well watch our first
person sure let's do that we could try
to salvage a stream alright do oh I'm
ready
like that guy was good like I knew
exactly what he was doing
come on play
what
so it's still in beta so it's kind of
glitchy too and I played before so much
sure how long slender blasting
well man this is weird
practicing headshot punches for what's
really lucky as you said several times
let's land right next to each other this
time well that kind that time we kind of
did yeah we were next thing I just saw
us go into that building and waited for
us guys orange
all right here we are
so it starts out in third person as you
drop do a meal and it's going to rock
share Feroz hawk
I mean I'll consider to win if we clear
Azam and that's been cleared if just
everyone leaves and we're still there at
this point I'll consider to win if I
just do something not embarrassing oh
god I did not mean to jump okay well
what do we do now son go to rod tuck
I'll meet you there
Jake you aren't oil and this minutes
seconds after I say let's land near each
other this time you just jump out to go
to the beach oh my god
sweet okay this is going with swell I'm
gonna land in your car I'm gonna drive
to you yeah no big deal yeah it'll be as
if nothing happened I see a car already
Mike we're already things are already
going as a bunch of dudes gonna rock
rock row shock that's fine that's fine I
forgot it's first-person mode already
yeah driving is gonna be fun get in the
right effing side oh you're already
getting in the car oh yeah I already
found a car nice all right
so uh I got a car too maybe you might be
near the circle just keep that in mind I
got an auto shop I shouldn't dude I
already feel like I have no sense of
awareness no spatial awareness the thing
is though no one else does right no
right yeah that's the one bright side to
this you gotta listen Mike you gotta
listen open your ears
I mean potentially I could see myself
liking this more and wouldn't even stop
talking for a second easier said that
done for me okay
so opening doors and closing doors is
already a problem
Oh 556 ammo all right it looks like oh
dude you know what I also just realized
you were right in the center I'm gonna
forget like what I have like on my back
and [ __ ] oh yeah
my memories not what it used to be yeah
yeah oh yeah
should I get in a Jeep or should I just
how did it get to you as soon as I can
uh that one what get in the Jeep come
come to me well you hear that oh you're
quite a few vehicles around me actually
I'm pretty far away if you didn't gather
that yet I mean I didn't know if you're
listening my gameplay audio dang I wish
we could cut to me now see how dang far
I am me accidentally jumping I could
show it you're on the other side of
poaching key alright I've got an idea
I'm gonna get out of this building and
try to go if I'm going to drive through
pinky they said I shouldn't I'm going to
oh man first person makes me feel ill
well I'm not like most being shot
someone else drop down there well I'm
driving through pachinko I think I'm
gonna die Mike
where is everybody looking through
windows as a chore now okay you can't go
360 with all Thai there all right I'm
almost dead and I got down the wrong way
got my duster
Mike I'm gonna go for the drop
oh wait into Ra'zac no I'm just kidding
I'm not gonna go for the travel I'm
coming to rock though yeah I'm coming in
hot baby I don't
comin in hot okay stop talking if you
find a health pack though save that I
have a way if I did cuz also what the
hell happened to you oh I took a wrong
turn
okay just were shooting at so I just
like melted well I meant like yeah what
happened to your date almost killed you
I know all right I'm gonna make a pit
stop at the school okay I'm just kidding
I'm not gonna do that
any guns for me uh no we've got a couple
for me though
I'm dead are you serious
I hit a rock oh my god Jake can you get
to me
where are ya probably give me a second
over there I know give me a second I'm
getting this stuff I don't have a second
oh yeah okay I'm coming I don't know if
you'll be able to get a car over there
where at why cuz you have to go over a
cliff how much health you have left I'm
bleeding out you mean you'll get to me
I wish I'd get up get up
I'm coming look you don't you die chicks
got luck tattoo tours ice I'm here you
idiot I know
all right I don't get why that hurt me
look what his gun no I hit a rock and I
did you fly out of the car no dude the
guy just took my car - don't report me
oh I didn't mean to do that stop I'll do
it dude just the story that played out
when I saw that your Jeep hit the rock
all right
I was just bait all right let's try that
again
whoops why does it keep canceling I
don't know
are you kidding play you might have to
refresh the UI that's what I had to do
last time there we go all right we're
gonna back into rock I don't care yeah I
agree
I'll try not to jump out too soon oh my
god that's horrifying don't you it i've
marbles for eyes all right I've got a
lot of pent-up frustration the Jeep is
into the rock
[Applause]
okay nope doesn't look like it will
still shoot for it though
how about
oh they mark the school on the map now
yeah chinki Yakka ruins ross awk
how about here
actually no [ __ ] no let's do the let's
do here huh yellow yellow I want to
actually try survive all right Scott
okay
little do you know that I jumped out ten
minutes ago
oh geez I wasn't paying attention whoops
get back yeah
a lot of people any appreciation I see
no one near us
I know rock better than I know some like
Halo Maps I know you ever landed a tree
and had to cut yourself out yeah
I've landed in a building I had to cut
myself out too and then I got launched
like 10 feet and died according sweet
nice okay
showing the gun that I picked up would
be great
I can't even reload it haha what is this
try switching weapons let me drop it and
then pick it back up okay thank you that
would have been funny because I would
have gone up to someone and pointed
invisible gun at them and pretended to
shoot them imagine if you won like that
Willy Wonka with m16s would have been a
very dark tale what no because you're
singing it okay all right I don't know I
was imagining a gun you think I'd be
else's here I didn't see anyone else
land here but yeah thing
do you want a crossbow no yeah no one
wants a crossbow oh my old friend and
nemesis the frying pan there's a couple
helmets here
doosh doosh doosh anything in here whoo
shocking I'll take that I took all the
ammo but cuz it was that shock and I
didn't take it that shotgun blows yeah
it's better than okay oh sweet cuz I
don't have any ammo I see what you're
saying Scott do you need a name no Jesus
um what are we gonna
it's a circle looking like anywhere
close yeah Oh
what's going on here no I don't want go
around particular here yellow sure let's
do it Oh
we ride wait a minute let me double
check these shacks nice nice so you got
a crowbar I went with the frying pan my
personal president find a frying pan you
know it's kind of like that's like if
now right I almost made a dumb joke um
where are we going let's go just getting
through this house oh you already came
in here let's play ball yeah let's play
some ball I drove through here last game
yeah and you're Jack Kerouac kind of
journey across this map
uh we're gonna yellow sure you can still
do all 360 oh not 360 but you can still
look side to side yeah that's pretty
good I know that
- doot-doot doot-doot doot-doot
doot-doot
[Music]
all right we are moving through a field
big ol fields are people can see us but
good thing Mike over here has an m16 you
can protect us from anything do you want
my holographic sight you have one yeah
but it's on my gun what kind of using
should we now you can give it
where we going to use yellow okay scope
this place out though he's just tree for
concealment climb it
where's the flight path this way so
there's gonna be yeah we could get to
the north side this trip will be the
best you guys not pulling aza or
whatever sure
let's check these buildings out of guess
which buildings
looks good to me that's alright I'll
follow you some stars
I have grenades if you want me to tides
that doors open oh yeah I see some I see
some open doors nothing nobody in here I
don't think unless they missed this
first aid pack
oh this is not yellow is it no whoops
hey I got some
health pack this a mess
maybe we'll find an m16 here nothing and
nobody
I don't even have a bag do we have to
move far not super far from where we are
should we move though soon yeah probably
I'm finished checking this building cuz
it looks like they didn't yeah I don't
think anybody came here oh my god it's
so annoying how you have to like
complete the reload action fully for it
yeah
gas masks or a cycle helmet what do I
have on right now marsai hamid got a
police messier level 1 if you don't know
I got level 2 seems m16 ammo dope I'll
grab it you can take it
all right you want to go yeah yellow
still yeah I have a lot of health stuff
let me check this out here quick you
lose it's kind of dangerous not that we
shouldn't go there just like mm-hmm be
careful oh I always am yeah that that
was more like me speaking out loud
because I'm not careful as evidenced by
the stream I'm not usually careful guess
I'll take these last bandages because I
already have 35 and I'm anything out
here before I go god dude I have way too
much first-aid it's a vehicle to the
south
I'm gonna do old yellow right now oh we
just got out of the bomb area oh dang
this is the road shoot I'm gonna get
across the real quick
there's a jeep up the road I saw that
yeah little - back back I'm gonna go
into the hills right now to check for
weapons cuz I still don't have that good
of [ __ ] all right
don't have a ton of time you're right we
don't I'll just finish checking this
building and move on
nothing
then run through this house as I moved
today car m16 car coming towards us II
sounds like I just drove by but here the
hell did it go okay did it stop is it
what I'm worried about
I didn't drove away okay oh yeah let's
go into the hills
anything behind us look like it let's go
angle left try go from the north kind of
out the open but get those trees maybe
check these buildings over here quickly
man this is right down up the hill from
the school yeah I bet there's gonna be a
lot of people pouring through here once
the circle moves mm-hmm Oh actually
people probably poured through huh
hopefully you've asked for the backpack
all right just keep white dog Vader says
yo what up let's go to mine I know him
buildings over here or just keep moving
let's just keep moving as well
oh man hope that looks far away is it go
to yellow I guess
I hate running up hills so much
you have to be pretty close to these
mics Jeff Murr - for them to pick
anything up they don't really get too
much ambient noise
[Music]
car
I don't hear it was up the hill I think
you hear it or I did I just heard it
alright let's keep going
some like they stopped did they
god this is scarier first person I know
shotgun ammo in here
[Music]
keep moving I guess for gunshots not
like to the right yeah yeah oh you're
not next to me yeah yeah I don't know
keep on moving I need a sight what side
you say you're using holographic but I
haven't m16s I'm gonna keep it
you don't have any others nope
damn you get to the ridge this Hill
right here and then look around doing
some m16 ammo
sure I have a 20 round worry about that
we get damn are you using it for
anything my m16 yeah I don't need looks
like you only got 30 I've got
Denton Denton Denton Denton
you know I should get this
get to these trees or something I should
go farther north I feel like yeah thanks
to the flight path was what Southeast to
Northwest I think mm-hmm
dang this field sucks we're here anyway
we got time
okay so this tree is quick
I love a site hopefully you will find
one soon
yeah donal red dot so it's better than
new from yeah where to hang out or get a
better position right here uh or just
had to keep heading north for now
yeah maybe keep heading north or wait
for the circle to figure out what it
does I don't know it could be people
anywhere it down this hill
why doctor Vader says I've only done a
few matches but all in all but all in
third person first person looks really
funny pretty fun we're playing
battlegrounds and you're not wearing
glasses
no wonder you know where that dude was
seriously I'm gonna check this check
but yeah it's more tense it's a little
janky - another read D site I'll take it
all right we're just circle going
she just hold up
sure did you do did you do uh this is
what this stream has been I know you
know I mean I was looking at trash bags
I'm just kidding we are really close
sweet
we're actually on a good side of circle
- I say we kept keep heading north all
right but we need covered this is uh
Jeff Jeff mer or is it her - the tunnels
says can you say what mites these are I
can't I can say the the software we're
using to capture and broadcast is called
xsplit oh okay straight ahead I'll hold
up mount ya up at 70 like 80 okay I'm
going where are they uh right at 75 [ __ ]
yeah all right where's his buddy
I don't know I'm getting tunnel is the
tunnel a good idea I'm waiting for him
can you can you yeah just wait there
tell me where he is he's on the other
side of this the tunnel mound I got a
heal up can you cover me they're just
like companies coming around right yet
yeah got em both all right I got a heal
[ __ ] can you we have time right we're
not know you I think we're good yeah the
sheriff of shelter yeah you come into my
shelter try to put do your own rules in
my town you dirty drifter this is a
quiet town some might even call it
boring but that's the way we'd like it I
just watch the entire trilogy yeah
recently uh now you're confusing your
life with Rambo again so graphics
yeah yeah yeah yeah Oh gunshots I'm
gonna go prone really fast with this
inventory by any chance could you uh
when you're done can you cover me cause
like oh yeah holographic
all right should be good I got five five
six ammo a lot of it oh he had a scar as
well if you want it I know I'm good
all right um couldn't hang on the tunnel
if we want although people could come
from down there if we're not careful I
think we're on a good side of circle I
don't know how they must have had the
same idea I'm keeping the shotgun I felt
good about that in first person
yeah you smoked that guy well he almost
killed me but yeah he he was waiting on
the other side of this door and I went
up the hill and dropped on him it also
proves my theory that the more
aggressive you are in this game the less
people know what how to fight you
I just forget it I kind of agree with
that I kind of got a little excited but
it worked do you have first aid I mean
why I'm a ton of first date I have four
forsaketh thirty bandages and anything
and a red dot sight if you want it I'm
putting my pistol I guess right yeah
yeah I'm good all right circles close
and then we should okay yeah you're
watching down there thank you because
that could very well never look the same
direction battlegrounds 101 yeah hold
shift level up gaming it hold your
breath you see the lung capacity at the
bottom right but it also like steadied
your aim and like that was actually one
small thing I didn't know you could do
when I first started playing like a lot
ik first-person PC games do that but
yeah this helps especially when you're
sniping yeah alright about to find out
where we need to go only 30 people left
hopefully it's a sheriff of shelters
[ __ ] complete opposite - he left società
steak up to the hills you want to wait a
little bit I hope someone no one's
around this tunnel one let's go out one
at a time I'll be the bait stick to the
north and east to the east if we can get
over there as much as we can okay yeah
because you your gun doesn't like you
don't move that slowly when you're
crouched it's hard to tell if I'm
crouching I know got the road dirt road
Oh take me home
Virginia what we're trying to get up on
this hill yeah I guess so uh I just also
I think they're farther east and the
circle we are the better least less
likely we're gonna see people yeah Oh
can't you both take now who do you play
I'm messing up the lyrics bad I feel
like circle rarely closes around here
yeah I agree I don't I think I'm fine
with equipment barring a new site that I
might find alright keep moving I guess
there's a car right next to you like who
drove up there where you see that the
Renault am i right
that's worrying you want to get in it
mmm should we go far do we have to go
no never mind yeah let's not get in it
23 people left though I'm the Bandit of
Roz Hawk but currently I am the deputy
because Mike needs know I'm the sheriff
of shelter I left when I got to kill at
shelter I uh
this badge became a new source of pride
got the vinegar boiling up inside me
when we get into a firefight okay
interesting predicament here because the
yellow is right on this Ridge and
there's a house do you want to let's
hang out for a second wait for the
circle actually let's keep going toward
that house okay let it be careful I do
want to come in from the east side of
the circle that'd be way better yeah
watch this house though yeah looks fine
to me for now Oh circles coming too geez
I just forgot about the see ya I gotta
run in why the lights on this Jeep it's
someone in there do you see that someone
in the back no what the hell is someone
in this house then we gotta move [ __ ]
damn that came fast I'm gonna hit the
deck right oh I'm getting shot at I'm
dead from where probably up from that
house oh I've no idea down the hill
quick they're out of the circle oh man
are they in this town probably I'm
crawling to you uh give me a second oh I
see him I'm gonna die damn I'm dead
yeah Wow okay should we try one more
third person and call it no that might
be it we should call it there now one
more third person no we gotta call it
there don't do this this is health
streams gone for two hours all right
we'll do one more third person but we're
making it exciting okay drop it into
whatever town that's all usually what I
want to do all right last game I don't
have much going on today I don't care um
all right remember to switch from do you
you're in control so we'll just touch it
automatically
he agrees this show should be renamed
one more John the nerd says hi Jake I
know him too my ego is not taking a
beating my ego is invulnerable
you'll never just take down money you
get my ego it will always stand strong
I'm still the sheriff of Rock Gym sure
hey hey hey how you doing you busted hey
hey how you doing you're busted you're
out crooked caps I haven't decided if
the sheriff is like a Wild West sheriff
or an actual like modern-day the wire
kind of detector Wild West yeah that's
more actually maybe you should save the
Wild West persona for the desert battle
looks like you've graphics set to the
highest quality no actually it was ultra
when we bumped it down because of
splitting the difference being rock and
poaching key I think I know where I want
to go pachinko I think I know
are you or will they let you back in
Rostock but I got a ride back in on this
on a ride back in on my horse with my
gun Lucille my horse
Craig Dan we're not gonna reach Roz like
re-screw it's cope with [ __ ] we try
sake you can't reach rock yeah go yellow
screw it open okay
okay babe anybody know why was there no
one else in for cheating girls scared
I'm going to Lego on the sheriff it's
dropping I'm not going there
yeah say bottom tip yeah
see anyone yep a couple on night oh yeah
yeah there's a lot there's quite a lot
the bottom tip might be spoken for
whatever
god I hate how fast how slow these drop
that guys let's double-team this dude
and this guy make a clip of me saying
that again this house I need a gun no
get these right next to you I know his
buddies running into a building I'm
getting a gun I'm coming over here as
fast as I can give me a gun good
backpack okay sweet found a backpack get
wall nothing still still enough and I'm
trying to find something oh my god pick
up the crowbar you dumbass oh yeah I got
him 16 where you I'll come to you oh my
god I reloaded oh my god like okay okay
my bad with my little hot can barely
take it no more for that I don't know
give me someone to shoot
it's gotten quiet too quiet he branched
off and yeah no idea whipped out baby
don't don't don't don't don't don't
don't don't Shh you want across whoa
Mike know where these boys at I'm in I'm
in another shirt oh my god she's in here
with me I'm dead
well why is always you this I don't know
it's like you have bad luck uh where are
these boneheads oh I'm good I know what
I'm gonna do
well that was a dumb last you see that
guy oh it's not laughs that's not over
yet where the stairs I heard a drop on
him too I'm out come on we can't leave
on that I'm not no I'm not playing I'm
done by someone need a stream with me
see if someone else wants to come and
we'll keep going okay fine why my
clothes off there we go all right well
thank you guys for tuning in we didn't
do as well as normally not that we
normally do that well but yeah that was
rough but anyway I think you guys for
watching we are streaming every day at
11:00
Pacific time so make sure to come and
check that out I'm up G every Monday
well I don't know we might switch to
something else soonish but we'll see not
until we get a chicken dinner though
yeah um
how many you have now three four I
haven't played in a while though I've
never got a solo but I met four as well
all right yeah I'll be back next week
what are we doing tomorrow
it's Tuesday Tay what's taking to be
playing I don't know all right see you
guys later have a good rest of the week
see ya
you